First time I saw a poker game
was in a barber shop when I was
8-years-old.
And I asked my grandfather--
I said, what were they doing?
He said, they were
playing poker.
I was hooked ever since.
[MUSIC]
Ivey shoves the river.
Got a trick or
two up his sleeve.
Very intimidating
glare and a little smirk.
Welcome to Ivey's world.
[MUSIC]
You'd just love to get inside
his head for five minutes.
[MUSIC]
To Paul Jackson, he has a
very famous hand in poker.
I had queen, 8, he had 5, 6,
and the flop was jack, jack, 7.
And I bet.
He raised me.
I re-raised him.
Both guys with nothing.
Key point was when I asked
him how much chips he had.
$360.
The way he answered it
made me pretty confident he
didn't have anything.
All in.
What?
It's just mind-blowing what we
just witnessed from Phil Ivey.
I come from a generation
where the good players
knew talking about a hand or
helping someone to improve
was a big no-no.
But maybe it's time that I
share my keys for success.
I'm Phil Ivey, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC]